you're so bad at telling your own story
what you just said the intro this is my
story you want me to tell well well I
would say yeah I would say I started a
quilting company called Missouri
quilting Missouri Star Quilt Company
Missouri Star Coil Company it's a
behemoth of a quilting company can you
say what the revenues are uh yeah it's
the biggest let's first start with that
it is the biggest it's the biggest it's
the biggest it's uh let's see we're
we're 400 some employees over 100
million in Revenue like it's a it's a
bigable it's a big old boy
[Music]
foreign
it was like our Insider's joke and we in
the email we'd be like you know like
this young kid who just raised a bunch
of funding like he's gonna be one of the
greats like Elon like uh Steve Jobs or
or Hoobastank or you know like when
people notice would you get replies
every once in a while so I put it on my
LinkedIn I put that I'm the the
webmaster of the hoobastankfanclub.com
and when you endorse the skill it's like
hoopa's thinking well and when I wanted
to like make a joke with someone I would
email them from Sam
hoobastankfanclub.com yeah yeah I still
haven't yeah
dude you got to give your intro who are
you what do you what would you say you
do oh yeah yeah uh I'm Al Doan what do I
do I uh uh not not as much right now I
just shut down a a software company I
own or I'm the own and the executive
chairman of uh of creativity Inc which
is you know it's got a quilting company
a big quilting company and a a knitting
company and an art company a lot of a
lot of stuff in that space dude you're
so bad at telling your own story uh what
you just said the intro this isn't my
story you wanted to tell well well I
would say yeah I would say I started a
quilting company called Missouri
quilting Missouri Star Quilt Company
Missouri Star Coil Company it's a
behemoth of a quilting company can you
say what the revenues are uh yes it's
the biggest let's first start with that
it is the biggest it's the biggest it's
the biggest it's uh let's see we're
we're 400 some employees over 100
million in Revenue like it's a it's a
bigable is a big old boy you own the
largest quilting company in the world it
does over 100 million dollars in revenue
and you also have now bought two towns
it was so so the quilting company in
Hamilton right we we bought the entire
downtown district so 27 buildings
downtown because you had to or because
that's awesome no this was the so like
when we started this Quilt Company the
the challenge is like there's 3 500
quilt companies in America right like
they're in every little city and you're
saying that like we know that yeah like
right you know yeah
doesn't really pull the eyeballs in and
so I like there's no ESPN for Quilters
right I can't just go advertise for this
so I'm like how are we gonna get this
and so our uh like we were in this
little town we uh we we grew big enough
online that we had to like like we
couldn't fit all the the inventory in
our space they're in our in our store
and because like we could either go open
a warehouse which would have been the
normal same thing to do or we're like
we're like man it's awesome because when
people come to our town There's normally
no customers and so like the the
impression you get if you walked in
there it was just retail is like
nobody's here and this is really sucky
and so instead we had like 12 people
cutting and fulfilling fairs you'd walk
in and there's like this energy this
Buzz that was happening in the shop and
so we split it out and bought her and
bought the the next building over and
put fabric in there and then I was like
man
who has the most quilt shops of any town
in the world right like that was like
it's the biggest Wooden Nickel in
Minnesota this was going to be my thing
and uh some town in Germany I think had
four and I was like we're gonna we're
gonna take it you wanted to create a
tourist destination yeah you're quilting
just just be a novelty right it was just
supposed to be a novelty and so then we
ended up Dollywood or whatever I mean
like if you're driving by on the highway
you're like the most are you kidding me
all right let's go see it yeah and so in
that process dude we got like we people
were coming to town we only had like
Subway in the gas station for food so we
started restaurants so we've got to
sleep and so we're like it's a slumber
party for ladies to come and they so
you're saying it right now like it's
like you know this is a natural thing to
do but like the first part of the idea
which is like let's create the town with
the most let's create a tourist
destination that's not what most
companies do so you you have this idea
from where and then aren't people saying
yo this is crazy we don't have to do
this and you know do you and your family
own the whole thing yeah yeah so you're
able to do crazy well we're bootstrap
but like dude fabric a fabric company is
a hard thing to bootstrap because like
like fabric you order your fabric six
months before you get it we're growing
200 a year we gotta hold the fabric for
nine months recover your your initial
costs in the first 90 days right so that
you can cover terms and like it's like a
really complicated we're betting the
farm every three months and like if
we're wrong we go under so if you do 150
million in Revenue how much uh eBay that
can do uh so we're like a normal
e-commerce or like e-commerce business
so our goal is about 20 we're not there
yet especially this year right but like
well like that's where we that's where
we'll end it but then you take the
profits out and buy yeah I've made like
seven nickels I pay myself a fine salary
but like but like all the money goes
back in right next purchase order next
purchase order well because because
we're growing by significant amounts
every year and most that gets tied up in
inventory in two years what do you think
you could sell the business for well our
goal right now man well I I I think we
can get 20 growth for a couple years
right which should move our valuation
like a 5x Revenue so like a billion
dollars yeah that's the that's the idea
how many uh is your like is it like your
wife or your sister your mom who who all
is the shareholders so like your whole
family's gonna get yeah so it's me and
my sister and my buddy Dave or the uh
are the are the main ones and then like
all of our family just this year just
this year we cut in like all of our
employees that have been there for any
kind of time and that's a cool feeling
but you started it with your mom or your
mom started and you no tell that a
little bit so the idea like me and my
sister been talking about starting a
company for a while I was I was like a
year out of college right and so like I
I was uh I don't know everybody's sort
of an entrepreneur right out of college
that's what I'm gonna do and and we're
sort of that same way and my mom had
taken a quilt into it to the quilt she's
you sew the top together and take it to
a lady that's got a big forty thousand
dollar machine and they're gonna Stitch
all the the backing and the fluffy stuff
in the middle and the top they're gonna
Stitch it all together and this lady was
out a year and she's like I made your
sister a quilt I took it in I'll get it
back in you know 2008 and I'm like
nothing takes a year to do like you can
build a house in less time than it takes
to get this quilt done and so either
she's terrible or there's a lot of
Demand by the way that was literally my
market research I was like
there is going to be a market here for
this are there others she's like yeah
everybody's backed up and when you say
quilt like literally just a blanket
right shut up okay how dare you yeah
but I mean like like because I know some
people like hang [__] on their walls
yeah yeah so some people have like a
decorative quilt and then some people
like I had a quilt like comforter yeah
yeah it's it's exactly that and like my
mom's stick uh is she's like she's like
the McDonald's of quilting right because
quilting like most of these hobbies are
very like I don't know like very defined
you know there's there's a quilt police
that's going to come and get you if the
if the seams are off or whatever and if
your points don't match and every I feel
like getting into any hobby there's that
sentiment meant that you're like I can't
go to the group yet I'm not good enough
right and so uh mom's like no no finish
is better than perfect look and our big
innovation did we made like the the Lego
blocks of quilting right so it's a pack
of five inch squares and a pack of ten
inch squares and you sew them together
and cut them like this and whack a mix
of this and so like really simple tricks
and techniques she was a costumer uh
when we were saying McDonald's because
he like kind of made a process out of
his Burger making process where it's
like anybody can make this burger well
no I'm saying McDonald's because it's
like it's like not fancy right it's not
you're not spending a lot on it it's
like it's you're trying to do it to get
to the it's serving the purpose of
filling you with food right I mean I
mean it's funny because like quilting I
never thought that uh you know cool my
business buddies and stuff will sort of
laugh at like my whiteboards like layer
cakes up 17 turnovers down you know
jelly rolls we gotta get these back you
know it's like it's it's all sort of uh
you know goofy terms for people that
aren't in the space but like man it's
it's a 45 to 70 year old demographic as
the major already my customers and there
are so few people building awesome
experiences for them that like I I feel
like a you know a line among sheep being
in there just like we're gonna build
amazing great experiences for these
people and Sam Spray sure that is a a
dwarf amongst midgets yeah no everybody
normally says that a dwarf amongst
midgets that's very clever it's not
allowed anymore but we're both
missourians we probably grew up in
somewhat similar environments and that
was a phrase and I like that and like
it's the same people right
is like a tall [__] look like that's
just a phrase I didn't even realize it
was like don't cancel them all right I
didn't realize it was bad another one is
tough titty said the kitty but the
milk's still good have you heard of that
one yeah yeah sure so anyway what do you
think it's gonna be like in
two or three years if you ever sell I
mean are you guys like you're gonna be
the richest person in like by hundreds
of miles we're gonna do just buy
thousands of Acres no I mean what do you
what do you do these are crazy because
that's what he says this feels very
aggressive the way that you're phrasing
this I'm just gonna say that right now
uh
uh the the well the idea is not like I
don't know if I don't know if we'll sell
it right but there's a big question in
my head of like of like I don't my my
main say is like I don't want my kid to
grow up and say I gotta be a quilter
because pop was a quilter right it's
like oh it's a business you got to get
in here there's all this time there's
tough titties
uh but uh but like I so I'm trying to
figure out how to navigate around that
like how like is there uh how do you
maximize value and create the most
opportunity and all that kind of stuff
I'm very attracted to a Finish Line
right which uh an IPO or a sale or
something would be but also you know get
to the point where it's shutting off Eva
done it's a very even gonna just keep
running 12 years yeah you didn't know
were you even like into quilting before
that like were you in it no my mom makes
me she's she made me make one quilt
she's like you can't run this company
and not be a quilter so I I've made one
I'm making another right now a nice bear
paw on point so what did you know how to
do you didn't you you worked at you were
a software guy these are such mean
questions
no I
the funny thing is at this event why are
you just basically been having an
intervention because he's asking
questions that he thinks are completely
normal questions that everybody's been
like and women can't hate you that's so
weird yeah people are like Sam when you
ask questions it's like a full frontal
attack he's like what do you mean well
he's like completely oblivious to the
fact that these questions are
outrageously aggressive
so like his mom is like the face of like
their YouTube and he was explaining to
me what she was like and I I looked up
the YouTube I'm like oh she looked
exactly like I expected he goes what the
hell I was like what I expected her to
be like at night she's like that was a
compliment very rarely is oh she looked
exactly how I thought she would a lot of
misunderstandings going on I was like I
thought she sounded like a lovely nice
woman yeah yeah and who's cool and I was
like and she looks like it sweet Dorothy
man but uh well and when he also said
that you owned 200 acres and you like I
do own so I like like this
I'm 100 hillbilly Rich right like like
give me a hundred million dollars
tomorrow my life doesn't change at all
right uh I've got I've got a a car that
I like to drive I've got a house that I
like to live in I got three beautiful
boys and a wife and uh beautiful wife
also I mean beautiful extent so all of
them and uh and like I'm I'm done right
and so it's sort of a weird spot where I
don't need I don't need the Finish Line
the the only value that a Finish Line
would offer is like the past the mantle
right like I no longer wake up and and
have to stress about like what if we
ruin it all tomorrow what if the person
that we hired to do this like screws it
all up what were you good at that oh
yeah yeah what skill what what
attributes did you bring to the quilting
table great question great questions
yeah uh not a lot like like uh I mean I
so I came out of I came out of college
uh and and my first job was with
semantic like I I was a really good uh
kind of networker right and and uh not
not networker but like I I like people
that I like and I hate people that I
hate I like some guys that like you're
the most popular guy in the house right
now by the way I don't know if you know
for real there's like 25 people here
there's some famous people everybody's
like big everyone's got a different
nickname for you it's a big out then
somebody's like big city because he's
buying cities and other guy's like oh
good and so big city is a cool name yeah
it's like you know Tom big city yeah I
mean it's like Hood it's like calling
like a really tall guy shorty or
something you know this is perfect it's
better than big country I get big
country a lot but big city no it's not
funny when you are oh you know you'd
have to be like tiny country or
something like
that'd be some opposite thing yeah no
big cities okay I think but anyways
you're super like I was calling out
there like what did you go you go
like he's Rich he's smart and he's and
he's funny and I was like yeah you need
to be the next Bachelor dude you know
like this is amazing you meet him
well I mean I don't even know Patrick
was on the Patrick came on the Pod that
was the first time I thought about the
word quilt it's like 12 years well he
was telling my story and all my buddies
were like dude you were on this podcast
dude you got to check this out so I'm
like what the crap
I was like oh man that's my story like
if you want to hear it what's happening
there's this there's this niche market
of quilting that's way bigger than
people realize and I was like what
really we remember we were like Blown
Away
and then we were like what's he's like
yeah there's companies that are huge the
conversation was great because you're
like oh that's red man love to hear it
sometime do you bone
I think I ghosted you for like a month
yeah and I was like okay by the way yeah
I do want to talk about that but more
importantly you want to meet up in
person and play basketball you didn't
know anyone here right no no no yeah
this is this is great did you even know
Patrick no oh wow no I've never met any
of these guys you took an amazing
and I'm turning out to be like six foot
seven and love playing basketball and uh
yeah
except you dude you smoked us for the
for the championship game drained three
threes in my face yeah I like the
greatest moment of my life today so you
know it's okay so okay so you do the you
do the quilting thing no wait wait wait
my skills before this uh just just
buddies that like that like connect me
up so I was working in a software
company lost that job uh in dramatic
fashion I've never been without a job at
the time what does that mean like got
fired yeah like me and 20 000 people got
laid off in 2008 right and uh and so I'm
you know I'm like Consulting and trying
to like just hold you I was
26 in Missouri yeah yeah uh but like but
well I was like living in Boston at the
time they moved me out there and I was
visiting my buddy up in Toronto and then
I moved in with him and his wife and
their new baby you me and Dupree style
and it was like we'll start a company up
here let's hear let's do it so we tried
like three of them we tried an ozone
cleaning technology that we'd sell to
real estate agents and that was like a
terrible time to sell to real estate
agents since 2008 and uh we try to do a
little wealth management thing because
he wanted to be a wealth management
advisor and so we tried to start that
and then uh and then this The Quilt
Company we had already and I wanted to
do like a daily deal version because at
the time it was hot right it was like
woot.com and Steep and Cheap and uh and
like chain love and all that stuff man I
loved those in college because they were
they were great and I'd wait up till
midnight which in in Hawaii where I was
going to school was like it was like
seven o'clock right and I'd be like wait
to see what it is still cool it's cool
but like I but like it hooked me as a
college kid and like every site was
built for like for like are you a dude
that loves riding bikes get
chainlove.com and there's a new thing
every night and but like nobody was
building them for the 45 to 70 year old
demo and so when I did the Quilter's
daily deal I think it was literally the
first time anybody had done a daily deal
site for my demographic which is like a
a discounted fabric well it I mean it
was discounted items right okay and like
it did at the beginning it was so funny
because like I was I was the guy doing
it all we were just scrapping our way
through it so like I'm I'm not a good
writer for my mom right where like I'd
write these stories like hey ladies like
so we started a forum and the the first
six months of the Forum because nobody
wants to join an empty Forum I was Genie
B and Sarah Sue and my buddy Dave was
Carmen and Elizabeth and we just had
these like all day
yes uh what kind of cool did you make oh
that's so cute that's the brother and
eventually now it's like 90 000 members
and like it's a great old thing wow so
that's really so you but your mom had
must have had some following or
something is that how it started no she
had zero following nother with the Forum
no no we launched so the the chronology
we launched with the website that I like
sat and built we launched with the store
that we started she was doing quilts and
then I I built this website on one and
one.com if you remember that old shared
hosting man it was a design they lost my
site a couple times like I'll start over
thanks guys and uh built this site and
and it was a daily deal site that I
would change at midnight I didn't have
any Automation and I was just like go in
you know be on a date and be like hold
on a second I gotta talking to my
quilting website and change it up tens
of women are waiting for this yeah and
we do we launched it I still have the
Facebook post in like February 2009 and
it's like hey I made a quilt chat for my
mom check it out two likes right like
zero orders the first three weeks and
and but like every day I'm going in
there writing these things you didn't
give up didn't give up didn't give up
yeah just like uh well I mean it was it
was a marketing challenge at that point
right like we knew we knew that we had a
product that was interesting oh like
like we're selling fabric online and
like the other sites were like were like
built on Yahoo stores and crap and I'm
like I can like there's a way better
experience for this and we're just gonna
we're gonna take better pictures this is
our novelty we're gonna we're gonna sell
it better and uh and so we we kept
working at it just thinking we had to
figure out how to find people and our
dude like I would write these deals
every day and be like like they were
always some version of the Pinocchio
nightmare scene I'm like and then he
turned into a donkey and then he was in
the whale's belly and jumbo rickrack is
3.99
things I like I was just trying to be
creative because Luke did it too they
were pretty funny well dude I was
modeling after that and just trying to
like be humorous and and turns out like
my mom's like this isn't good you need
to stop doing this is weird my buddy
Dave ended up doing it for the next the
next while and he was much better than I
was but uh so we we went three weeks
without a sale finally my cousin
Jennifer ordered something and so that
you know we're like oh that's all right
thank you Jed that's very nice and uh
and we'd get like an order to a day and
one day one day we meant to price
something like 288 it was the Crazy
Eights charm pack we meant to price it
at like 288 accidentally priced it at 88
cents we sold like 11 of them but but
shipping was five dollars right and so
like our cost on it was four or
something and so we're like we still
made money like this works and the
average order size was actually like 28
dollars like dude a loss leader we
should lose money on this in a
meaningful way and we can build this and
so it turned in like the deals are are
great deals people love them and uh but
that's what ended up building our
business and then as we went like
wherever you get Fabric and supplies
from we buy them from vendors so like
even even today there's probably 40
vendors that we buy from then to grow it
we started uh making videos like the the
education stuff YouTube was only a year
and a half old at that point and so like
you know late 2008 early 2009 and uh
there's like there's like this guy
quilting Buck on there and it's like a
webcam that he'd show on his quilt that
and he was it was cool people were
trying to do stuff and nobody had like
done it well and so I bought like a
Canon digital elf that was like the best
resolution at the time and just like
held it in my hands and and uh you know
the manual zooming stuff but like got
Mom to start doing these tutorials and
because I'm a 30 year old bearded guy
I'm like don't say you're lingo right I
need you to talk to me so I can
understand I'm not a dummy I have no
idea what what a wolf is right with the
fabric I mean like I'm like because
normally teachers when they try and
start teaching they'll try and like like
give themselves some uh some validation
by like look I know all the cool stuff
and I'm I'm I'm nerdy like you guys and
I just wouldn't let Mom do that so she
had to speak in a way that anybody could
understand we became this very
approachable if you've never made a
quilt you start with Mr with Missouri
Star and because we were making this
content every week we'd put it in our
emails that we'd send out and it was so
like we'd lead with that it was like we
made this great new tutorial for you
with all these cool tricks and tips and
stuff and uh and we we had ended up with
like a 70 open rate on our promo emails
which is just the magic that we built
around and you your 12 year you're 12
years in you're like 150 or something
like that Revenue what were the first
five years do you think uh first year
was a hundred grand then we did a
million then we did four then we did
eight and then we did 14.
and it did it it kept going at that rate
yeah yeah it would and but but again man
like bootstrapped through that was
intense at one point were you able to
pay yourself and make money uh so we
paid Mom after three years right like
it's crazy because I have I have like
seven siblings in my family and five of
them work on the quilt company like we
couldn't have done it if they couldn't
have just like worked for free for the
beginning and like I mean it's it's like
volunteers right well what year was it
making enough money we're like [__] it
let's buy a town well so so uh
four years in we bought our second
building right or three years been we
bought our second building and like we
remodeled it all ourselves we did all
the work and then we bought you know we
we piecemeal the beginning one like it's
we can look back on it now and be like
oh yeah well we got we got everything
this is great we did a good job but like
that was never the intent in the
beginning my thought was that like
people would see that we were bringing
more people to town and they'd start
these other businesses and do stuff and
uh and by the time like because we were
running so far ahead of our own curve uh
we just ended up with like our whole
downtown and now we have like like
there's a few other businesses in town
but uh and just they're like
because what normally happens if you
start to like buy everything in a town
like there's always like one or two
people who are like I'm gonna hold out I
don't know like you know oh yeah you
negotiate like yeah because you need it
you need to complete the set and then
tiny comes knocking on their door
you cannot promise you protection
like did you guys run into that like
like the average price for a building in
a small Missouri Town like that was
about 20 grand and uh and by the our
last building is about 80 right so so we
I just bought this other town down the
road from us Kingston right and so like
Steps in Missouri yeah so seven miles
down the road is our County like with
the really nice like King like well they
have a huge is that on the way to Mizzou
from St Louis no I'm thinking of
Kingsland yeah yeah yeah no Kingston is
not by me and uh on the other side by
Kansas City it was seven miles from our
town and uh and so we bought it's it's I
think it's eight buildings and it's like
it'll be like 70 000 for all of them
right wow and so they're just these old
like condemned sort of overrun buildings
we'll we'll put two million into them to
get them fixed up right but like but
like the the real estate is cheap and
the fact that it's already there and
we're just kind of fixing what's theirs
do you uh it's great I mean I lived in
St Louis which is way bigger than where
you're from but even that's not a
competition
but even St Louis I felt like oh [__] no
one gets me I feel like a freak here
because I'm building this internet [__]
and so that's why I left and I moved us
eventually San Francisco and there's a
reason why like a lot of companies are
started in San Francisco or New York or
Chicago or Austin like these like bigger
cities because you you meet people and
you like spread ideas and you like are
inspired by one another whatever and
like rubs off on you each other other
than
the internet which is I mean where were
you learning how to do all this stuff
and did you ever feel like what the hell
man I need to get out of here
I can find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out-of-sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
uh so after college I actually left this
part out this is a cool part after
college I uh when I when I lost my job
this was uh let's see 2009 I I declared
my year of the MBA right I was looking
at like going to back to Harvard I lived
in Boston it was like I should I should
really go SP it was like 200 Grand to
get us to get an MBA there and I was
like man that's that's too much money
for this broke farmer and uh and so I
declared the year of my MBA I emailed
all the guys were like successful in
business we're like What are the three
books that you'd recommend I read and I
got like a a constrained list of uh of
like 37 books right and so I bought them
all on Amazon for like 200 dollars and
then I I had a bunch of buddies who were
like doing cool stuff that I wanted to
try like a guy was doing import export
out in Hawaii and and another dude was
doing like venture capital in Salt Lake
and and so I was just like let me come
work for free for you guys for like
three months I just wanna I'll shine
your shoes and make your coffee I just
want to see how you run your business
and uh and so I like I hopped around
some of that and then I got into uh like
like I got to be an intern in Tech Stars
in 2010 right so like which one Colorado
Boulder yeah so it was only Boulder
Boulder in Seattle but like um
and Nicole glero's 2010. and so like
while I'm building this Quilt Company on
the side we've got these like
world-class mentors coming and like
they'd Mentor these companies doing you
know cool robots you're listening to all
these office hours yeah dick Casillas
super interesting what would you do if
you had a quilt company man
how would you like a deal daily yeah it
feels like deals right okay it was so
like I was getting like this I noticed
you reached for your phone when I said
that are you trying to tell somebody
about this talk to me about what are you
feeling right now yeah no so I was
getting this way outsized like brain for
for the internet stuff and I I always
thought that I would do something like
like I thought it was going to work for
Microsoft or Facebook or something right
and uh and and in the end in the end
like I just took all the learnings that
I had from this and my desire to sort of
be an internet Tech entrepreneur and uh
and shoveled all that into into this
quilting company which is you know again
like it's it's very technology focused
uh way way early adopters on a lot of
stuff and like it's given us a huge
Advantage as we've as we built and stuff
because there's no other like dude
there's no kids coming out of their MBA
school trying to take my margins and
that's that's the acceptance once
Patrick told all your listeners
me over do you have piers and how are
you do you have like peers in the
internet world or Ecom world or you're
like you're chatting with on a regular
basis to be inspired by or learn from or
share ideas like I got buddies right
like I'm an angel investor I'm in 50
companies doing stuff we I have a uh
early stage fund that I run with some
buddies like like I'm still like these
are still friends we still talk but but
uh there's like from an e-commerce
standpoint honestly man like I think I'm
world class I think I I think I'm one of
the best brains at selling stuff on the
internet and that's awesome yeah that's
awesome also the the envy that like give
myself an NBA thing the way you approach
that that's like
that is so smart but also once you hear
that story like of course this person is
going to be successful as a hustler
right because you you basically do the
math you're like okay what do I want
what's the normal way to get there oh
this like kind of long two-year really
expensive way can I just get that like
that was my reason nine months for 250
and you're like oh yeah what if I just
emailed all the smart people ask them
what are the best three books I read all
those books and then I like go Shadow
you know the three stars for free for a
dude for like three months like like
Cohen and Glaros these guys they'll
still go to bed to me for me to this day
right because that three-month
investment that I made of like and dude
I was the first one in the last one out
like I knew I wasn't getting paid but
like I was trying to soak it all up and
uh you I mean you do that and like
they'll open every door you ever need to
get through what was the most game
changing book of all those that you read
uh well honestly dude it's this book
that's out of prick like I didn't I
didn't read any business books that
changed my life right like once you get
through like six or seven I quit reading
it because I'm like it's the exact same
thing the the principles for business
are the exact same just told in a
different Parable every time and
whatever your Parable is that's what you
glom on to say oh man it's good to great
that's the best one this one it's your
Bible
um but for me like the most impact was
this one called coming out of the Ice by
Victor Herman which is this uh this dude
that like uh went over to Russia and
like ended up being an amazing Olympian
athlete but like Russia wouldn't take
credit for us and he was like no I'm
America so throw them in jail for like
50 years and it's this crazy story that
I'm like this guy's an American hero
somebody should know this story but it's
uh like dude reading that well I felt
like my life was so hard it was like oh
oh no I'll be fine I do the exact same
thing I'll read uh it's like better than
therapy for sure you want the fast
version of therapy it's David Goggins
back in the day totally like I'll read
like uh like a book about Navy SEALS or
about like I just read about uh the
Cherokee uh Native Americans oh man your
problems
oh I'm like I'm such a punk yeah you
know what I mean I do the exact same
thing it's way better than business
books no it's like my favorite one out
of that whole list because because just
buddyman I was like oh this is the best
book I've ever read read this and I was
like all right I'm in man and uh that
one's still this day it's like great
but but like do the books and this is my
problem with college is like every
marketing class I sat through or
something I'm like oh this is your great
idea you say sell it for more than I
bought it
whatever
I'm glad I'm paying for this right and
it's all these professors that used to
be in the industry that you want to get
into that no longer are that might have
connections that could open the door for
you and so when I was looking at an MBA
I was like this this like what if I just
go to the people that are in the
industry right now and somehow network
with them like that's going to open way
more doors for me how many they're great
how many people do you we have 450
employees but how many of them are doing
like uh like white collar jobs like SEO
work yeah or like internet internet
related things maybe 100 of them 100 of
them how many of them live in the town
uh gosh I I don't know I think how many
of them are are on site in Missouri I
think we have like 40 remote like fully
remote like our engineering team is
remote like where are they like all over
from Seattle to Serbia right
um and then we have
then we have like our design team is
mostly remote like a lot of one of the
ones that makes sense to be remote or
remote
um but then like in town it was probably
250 of them they're like right there in
town he's buying a town with good
business besides like you had uh you
have a business and this is kind of like
uh adjacent helpful if I didn't have
that but if I was like oh there's this
kind of like abandon-ish town really
cheap real estate I could buy this I can
reinvigorate is that a good idea or no
like I think I think every company
should have a town well like they did
you know so we can list a few for uh
Henry Ford tried doing this in uh hello
Windows is up in Iowa they have their
own like like there's well a lot about
uh Bethlehem yeah they did and when a
lot of towns were built around like that
big coal mine or something like that but
but my thing is like is like every dumb
Internet Brand should should have one
right like like uh a buddy of mine does
uh well this this is my thought pattern
here is like it's like if you're a 10
year old girl and super into baking
where in America do I have to take you
nowhere right but somebody if they could
just take that opportunity to grab and
they're like and we're gonna have dutch
ovens in this store just going and
cooking stuff and then the KitchenAid
mixer you come and have the the
experience you're gonna come and spend
two weeks here try everything they've
gotten you're gonna learn how to make
all this cool stuff and then go home and
your mom's gonna be stoked to spend
three grand to give you the experience
because it's magic and the whole town is
built around and that's what you're
doing for quilting that's what we're
doing for quilt that's exactly there are
people people doing this for everything
like if I wanted to go they're cooking
people are like I need to go to Paris to
get that experience but like if I'm into
like cooking like let's say it's cooking
right and you go to Paris you go to
Paris and you take a class but it's like
you have not gone to the cooking Mecca
yeah right the the cooking Mecca looks
like we bought every building on this
street and uh and walk in this one we
have we have all the cake decorating
stuff in here and then we've got all the
baking stuff in here and then we got all
that you're gonna get in so you'll give
tours or I don't know what you want to
call it you know you sell the stuff
you're a retailer right yeah and like
tours tours are part of it like people
people well because when I go there I'm
all of a sudden a part of the community
right it's kind of something
right it's like you go to a brewery you
can buy the stuff or a winery it's like
uh like Napa is a good example of it
sure like wine it's like Napa when if
you're a consumer of it yeah right and
it'd be cool to go and take the wine
tour and do the whole thing if you're a
beer maker where in America do you have
to go there's no somebody should do it
right I forget who I was talking to but
they're like they oh uh Patrick right
he's from Wisconsin I was like it's
crazy man if I want to get into cheese
making give me the town that like it'll
teach me it has it has 20 stores and I
buy the cloth and you have every kind of
cloth and I'll buy the basket every kind
of basket like somebody's just gonna
take that branding and go build their
their town around it and like it's the
biggest Wooden Nickel in Wisconsin now
and I gotta go see it because it's not
what is this example you're giving out
yeah
so in Iowa dude driving down what what
is it I-70 Iowa city has as the biggest
Wooden Nickel in Iowa or in the world
what is a wood and nickel what is that
it's like a giant 16 foot buffalo nickel
that's like you don't even know what I'm
made out of Nicholas in the olden days
yeah it's a buffalo nickel a buffalo
nickel is just a nickel that was made
before like I love that I'm looking at
you like how do you not know Buffalo
like 1905
any nickel made in the 1800s I think it
had a picture of a buffalo yeah that's
right that's it the nickel used to have
a buffalo
Topeka as the biggest ball of twine
right like it's it's all that just the
roadside novelty come see the biggest
whatever the biggest pecan is in like
Minnesota I think or something right and
you're like all right I'm just gonna get
off this highway and go look at this
stupid huge pecan take a picture by it
and like then buy it so what are the
economics let's say somebody does this
like what's a what's a vertical where
you're like or like a category where you
like somebody should definitely do it
for an abuse so like we just had twins a
couple years ago and I wanted like where
do we have to fly to
if you're gonna have a baby and they
have the coolest experience you race the
the the you know the stroller around the
track and then you try 15 different cars
in America yeah yeah it should be in
like Lehigh Utah or something right put
it right baby nickel you've ever seen
yeah but like but like the novelty of
they have 20 stores and you're gonna go
and spend a week there and come out with
eight thousand dollars worth of baby
stuff is is the draw right you're gonna
all your shopping's done there every
baby products represented like that's
that's the novelty of it and uh the
economics the economics are going to
vary by like like interest to interest
where is the money made is it in the
retail the sales or is it in the land
appreciation because you now made a
destination is it just just more is it
just a retail business that has higher
than normal
I I worry that I'm doing a bad job
explaining this and if I am like let's
keep digging on it because it's great
but like we're just like so
so for for uh an internet business right
that like our company there's a bunch of
no-name warehouses on the internet that
sell fabric right but we are a little
quilt shop in Hamilton Missouri in fact
we're we're a cool quilt shop with all
this branding and all this cool stuff
that we've done and we'll never be the
nameless faceless Warehouse right so if
you're starting if you're starting uh
you know whatever whatever goofy company
you're doing right like the second you
open up a town so one of the guys here
he's doing like firebrandt right yeah uh
David Siegel and I'm like I'm like bro
like go go open up a retail store
because the second you do that I'm not
just buying from your crappy Warehouse
where you're you're importing it trying
to calm lift because you're like we're a
real place
and like people like this you'll never
come here even if you'll never come here
because 99 of your traffic never goes
there you're saying that that stands you
out against everything brand and our
split our split like we 90 of our
Revenue online 10 is in store a little
less than like eight percent in store
but but like our marketing is 98 the
town let me tell you the story about oh
Susie brighter quilton oh look at this
new display we did oh all this stuff
right and that's that's the story that
we tell uh wow most of our traffic or
most of our Revenue comes from online
sales right so that's why I'm saying
like dude if you're if you have a brand
that's fast so so many of these guys are
just trying to flip Shopify stores like
oh we import and it ships out of [__]
bomb and it's great it's like yeah but
like people know they're just getting
like scammed by I mean you're just
buying to resell and try and make a
profit and uh the second you build a
little bit of a of an experience around
it right like do the work to to build
the physical manifestation of your brand
it's the the company all of a sudden is
much much more interesting in my mind
let's say you uh you sell the company in
two years you're you're you or your
family collectively or maybe a bill uh
worth a billion you're not working with
quilting anymore what what do you want
to do you want to start another company
and what type of company what do you
want to do with your time I have no idea
I started a company I love called
pretzel this last like two years ago and
uh it was the it was the the photo roll
meets the credit card statement right so
we itemized all of your transactions and
show you this very beautiful like oh
here's all the stuff I bought it was I
thought it was super cool and like the
dude the SKU level data are aggregated
around the user was so interesting to me
and uh couldn't Finance it ended up
shutting it down and so like that was
that was my my big play at it and now
I've I've got some major PTSD of like I
never want to raise money again I felt
dude once you take somebody else's money
and like don't give them a return I'm
like I'm an investor I know it's fine
but I felt so bad dude it's so bad so
what do you want to do then uh well so
now I'm just doing Lemonade Stand stuff
right it's like like my therapist says
she's like I think you want to be da
Vinci you want to like design a bridge
and then a helicopter and then go paint
a chapel and I'm like yeah I think
that's what I want to do I just like I'm
gonna do little little Lemonade Stand
style businesses just like little things
that can't scale like what's an example
what do you mean by that like I want to
do a barbecue place right like and I'm
like oh yeah it'd be great and I'll like
have a have the meat the pickle the and
the sauce right like that'd be cool and
I could do The Branding amazing and as
long as I was cool to like Let It Die in
four months I think I'd really enjoy it
turned into like oh now I built this
thing I gotta grind it out like I'd be
miserable and uh and so I'll just try
like little stuff like that I I mean at
some point I'll get into another thing
but like right now when you're in your
early 20s and in late teens did you
think you were going to be wealthy and
then no no I I dude that's interesting
uh no not at all right and it's kind of
jacked it Jacks with your head a little
bit and like I never I never dreamed in
my wildest dreams that I would be where
I am today right and so like I was
talking to my wife a couple days ago I
was like I think I might need can we do
a vision board I've never dreamed of
like what else is out there what else I
wanna I wanna do with my life are you
like overshot what you had yeah yeah you
never re-picture it guys sometimes you
can over plan
I didn't expect this to work and so
Landing here Landing here I mean it's a
big it's a big thing in my head like
trying to navigate like like in a very
serious way of like I don't I don't know
when you remove the motivation of money
what do you do with the rest of your
life because so much of our of our world
is built around like gotta get money in
the same year dude I stepped back from
my company uh so the day-to-day work I
got married I bought a house and we got
pregnant with our first kid and I was
like every Milestone I imagined I ever
wanted to work for and like dude when
you're dating it's very it's a great
reason to go to the gym you're like I
gotta look good and all of a sudden I'm
married I'm like screw it you don't care
how many push-ups I can do like I'm not
going anywhere and it was like it was a
full-on funky depression like not not
like a depression like a lot of like
grown-up people have it was like a baby
depression for me but but uh like just
figuring out what I was supposed to
reach for was uh was a really hard walk
for me and where'd you like what was the
how'd you get out of that uh
yeah um
I I don't know well so like doing like
any man I just buried it inside and
moved on yeah
I'm heavy with the reboot guys I don't
know if you know like Jerry Colona over
a reboot he's like the like the big
exact coach yeah coach Steve Jobs some
other who's he coaching I I don't know
he's a nice man though and I like him a
lot he's like he coached somebody famous
like you know whoever yeah it was
because you're like a retreat now for
CEOs yeah like when I was running the
company dude well because I was running
the quilt company and it had grown to
like 400 employees and I was like I was
like 30 32 or something like I didn't
know what I was doing and when you when
you scale that fast and you don't you
you don't scale your own capacity to
lead uh I found myself like you know sit
down in a room and and I was immediately
like trying to make these other people
feel stupid so they wouldn't notice that
I didn't know what I was doing right
you're throwing bombs in your own
business you're like they get rich I
can't believe he did this thing and then
like after his opinion I'm not a yeller
Rick baby I'm so sorry you know that's
not me we're on the same team and uh and
like like I came out I was like man I'm
hurting the people around me I gotta fix
so I went on a on a boot camp Retreat
that they do and like I came out of that
and I was like I either I need to fire
my co-founders which was one of three
co-founders and I came back it was like
I gotta fire you guys they're like no
that's not gonna happen and we're like
oh what should we do so then we're like
oh well I'll step back and like we could
we can manage this transition but uh but
like to get to that point where I could
sort of say those words out loud like
man I can't keep doing this because it's
a family business and it's all it's the
town like I felt all that weight on me
and I couldn't get out and so what did a
lot of the therapy stuff and at this
point yeah psychedelics yeah no dude I'm
so I'm so intrigued by psychedelics but
like I I'm I'm Mormon right and so like
the idea of doing you're Mormon yeah
yeah
no you don't you're the coolest Mormon
I've ever met and you know Mormons here
so that's nice yeah thank you you didn't
have to say that there's one like in the
room but the uh but but uh no like I
like I think because the stance is very
murky in my from the religious
standpoint so I'm like I've got I've got
it a bunch of mushrooms encapsulated in
my medicine cabinet that I'm like Dre my
wife I'm like Dre's Someday I'm gonna go
walking on the land and I just don't
know where I am yet
I've never done it I'm completely sober
but I'm totally into it I'm trying to
convince my wife to do it my fears like
I just don't want to be the one guy like
oh he took it and then his brain snapped
and I'm like no I don't think that will
happen with you thank you I don't think
it would either because I've got a good
brain but if it did I do very soon drink
no I don't drink never touched it well
[__] I always thought like if I'm
because I don't drink either but I'm
like if I freak out I could just get
super drunk and I'll be okay you know so
you don't have that this Playbook feels
made up on the spot did you no
what is science
no I just don't like that's like my and
that's my parachute you know that's my
ex my escape hatch I was man I don't I
don't know at what point I'll feel okay
with it but like at some point I'm just
like wait so you bought it or you have
it yeah no a buddy of my a buddy of mine
is very he's like I'm good at onboarding
people in just like oh my god dude I'm
like all right I've never done it no and
I meet those people and they're like
dude it'll be so great so controlled so
safe
he's emotionally stable though yeah I'm
like I don't need this
I was like do I need to get sad first
the interesting part is just like it's
just like the the guys are like I have
my greatest ideas in there and I'm like
can I just I just want to see what some
of those ideas would be yeah I don't I
don't think I need the whole like I
don't need the trip you're only using 12
of your brand right now then you got
like your Barber that's like I saw Jesus
yeah he was there bro and I'm like oh
that could be cool too I mean all right
I don't know well dude this is awesome
uh you came here not knowing anyone we
got you on the pod
this is pretty sick you're the most
popular guy here did you enjoy meeting
some of these people oh this is a blast
this is a blast
[Music]